Bien, pues vamos a trabajar con algunos
problemas de porcentajes.
Quiero seguir trabajando con estos problemas de porcentajes y en esta ocasión vamos
a hablar de carteras, voy a suponer que mi cartera
tenía 95 pesos en el inicio del año, y además,
que mi cartera va a crecer a un cierto porcentaje,
mi cartera crece...
ehhh... supongamos un 15%, si, me parece una
buena forma...
un 15%... y entonces, ahora lo que me voy a preguntar
es, ¿cuánto tengo en mi cartera actualmente?
¿cuánto tengo en mi cartera actualmente?
en este momento... Muy bien y entonces
¿cómo puedo resolver este problema?
Bueno, si te das cuenta es un problema de porcentajes,
yo lo que necesito sacar es el 15% del 95 y sumárselo al 95, es decir,
empiezo con 95 pesos y a esos 95 pesos
le voy a sumar el 15% de 95 pesos.
¿Cómo me puede quedar mi respuesta?
95 más el 15% de 95, pero recuerda que cuando
quiero sacar el porcentaje de algo, lo veo
su forma decimal, es decir, .15,
.15 es el 15% de 95, .15 por 95.
Ojo, éste es un por y lo voy a remarcar más fuerte.
Muy bien, 95 más .15 por 95 y es que aquí
hay algo importante,
no es necesario solamente sacar el .15 de 95 porque sino me quedaría con muy poquito,
sino que como mi cartera creció, entonces además de mis 95 pesos iniciales,
a estos les voy a aumentar el 15%
de los 95 pesos.
Y bueno, ¿pues cuánto es esto?
Pues esto es lo mismo que 95 más...
y habrá que calcular cuanto es .15 por 95,
a´si que déjame ponerlo por aquí...
95 por .15...
por .15 y esto es...
oh no, espérame, aquí no tengo suficiente
espacio, mejor lo voy a poner aquí.
95 por .15, ¿cuánto es esto?
5 por 5 = 25 y llevamos 2, 5 por 9 = 45 más
2 = 47, después aquí pongo un 0, 1 por 5
= 5 y 1 por 9 = 9, 95, vamos a sumar,
5, 7 y 5 son 12, llevamos 1, 9 y 1 y 4 son
15 y después hay que recorrer el punto decimal
dos lugares, así que llegaríamos a 15.25. Vamos a ver si no me equivoqué, algo me suena raro.
5 por 5 es 25 y llevamos 2, 5 por 9 = 45
más 2 = 47, aquí vamos bien.
1 por 5, aquí hay que poner un 0,
después es 95, 5 y 0 es 5,
7 más 5 es 12 y llevamos 1 y entonces me queda 1 más 9 son 10 más 4 son 14, no son 15...
no espérame...
aquí son 14, 14.25, algo me sonaba que estaba mal.
entonces el 15% de 95 es 14.25 y tiene toda
la lógica del mundo, porque 95 es más chico
que 100 y el 15% de 100 es 15, entonces no podía ser más grande que 15, pero 14.25 es bastante bueno.
Entonces el 15% de 95 es 14.25 y a esto hay que sumarle 95 para obtener
cuanto dinero tengo en total actualmente.
Entonces, ya tengo que el 15% de 95 es 14.25
y a esto hay que sumarle 95, vamos bien.
Entonces déjame escribirlo por aquí, 95
más 14.25, esto es lo que quiero realizar
y ya con esto obtengo mi resultado.
95 más 14.25 y bueno, esto está fácil,
esto es lo mismo que 100... 109... 109.25...
109.25, perfecto.
Suponte que éste es un 2, éste es un 5 y
ya llegué al resultado, si al inicio del
año yo tenía en mi cartera 95 pesos, en
mi cartera crece en un 15%,
actualmente tengo 109.25 pesos, está perfecto.
Bueno, espero que no te haya confundido
bastante en este problema porque quiero ver otro problema a continuación.
Bien, veamos un problema que tenga que ver
también con carteras pero en un sentido distinto.
Imagínate que ahora, yo sé que empecé con
cierta cantidad en mi cartera y además que
mi cartera creció...
ahhh... se me ocurre en un 25%
y después del tiempo que tenía que pasar,
resulta que en mi cartera tengo...
ehhh... vamos a suponer 100 pesos, si está
bien, vamos a suponer que tengo 100 pesos,
mi pregunta es,
¿cuánto tenía inicialmente, en un principio?
Y ojo, fíjate que es un problema completamente
distinto al problema que estábamos viendo
hace rato, debido a que no nos estamos preguntando
¿cuánto voy a obtener al final?,
sino más bien, ¿cuánto tenía en un principio?
Y bueno, para llegar a eso, lo único que
hay que hacer es utilizar un poco de álgebra.
Voy a decir que "x" es la cantidad de dinero
que tenía en un principio, la cantidad con
la que empecé.
Muy bien, ya sé que "x" es la cantidad con
la que empecé y entonces si yo tengo
que mi portafolio crece en un 25%, "x" más el 25% de "x", pues es la cantidad que tengo al final,
es decir, 100 pesos, esto es justo lo que veíamos en el video pasado,
nuestra cantidad inicial más el porcentaje de nuestra cantidad inicial era igual a nuestra cantidad final,
es decir, "x" más .25 "x", recuerda que el 25% visto en su forma decimal es .25,
"x" más ".25x" es igual a 100 y esta es una
ecuación de la cual podemos despejar a "x"
, fíjate bien, utilizando álgebra llegamos
a una ecuación de primero grado en la cual
podemos despejar a "x", de hecho, si factorizo
a "x" me queda 1 más .25 todo esto multiplicado
por "x", es igual a 100.
Una "x" más ".25x" es lo mismo que 1 más .25
todo esto por "x" o dicho de otra manera
"1.25x" es igual a 100.
Y perfecto, ya tengo una ecuación de primer
grado bien sencilla de resolver, lo único
que hay que hacer aquí es despejar a "x"
y para esto lo que tengo que hacer es dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 1.25.
Y tal vez en un principio no te suene muy
lógico todo lo que estamos haciendo, sin
embargo sería muy bueno que regresaras el
video y lo vieras con cuidado y te vas a dar
cuenta de que tiene todo el sentido del mundo
lo que estamos haciendo, de hecho este tipo
de matemáticas las hago yo muy a menudo,
son matemáticas que sirven bastante, bastante
para encontrar por ejemplo una cierta tasa
de interés o algún precio sin impuestos, algo así.
En fin, vamos a despejar a "x" y entonces
lo que hay que hacer es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 1.25, del lado izquierdo
me queda "x" mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 100 entre 1.25.
¿Y cuánto es esto?
Ahora el problema, es que ya casi no tengo
espacio, entonces mejor déjame agarrar la
goma y vamos a borrar algunas cosas de aquí
para que obtenga el espacio necesario,
así que recuerda, "x" es la cantidad con la que
empezamos que es justo tras lo que voy.
Entonces voy a borrar todo esto de aquí y
¿qué será bueno?
También voy a borrar esto de aquí y esta
ecuación de aquí, espero que ya la tengas
apuntada o en mente, realmente no era muy
difícil, lo único que estábamos haciendo
era tomarnos 1.25 por "x", es decir, nuestra cantidad inicial más el porcentaje de la cantidad inicial.
Muy bien, y ahora sí, voy a hacer esta operación,
1.25 va a dividir a 100 y para esto voy a poner un punto decimal aquí y varios 0 por acá
y entonces hay que recorrer el punto
decimal dos lugares hacia la derecha,
entonces aquí adentro también voy a recorrer el punto
lo voy a poner justo aquí y me queda, 125 entre
10000, ¿cuánto es 125 entre 10000?
Bueno, 125 no cabe en 100, entonces voy a
agarrar el siguiente 0, 125 entre 10000,
125 entre mil cabe como 8 veces, 8 por 5 es 40,
pero vamos a hacer las cuentas más rápidas...
A ver, 125 por 2 es 250, 250 por 4 es 1000,
por lo tanto, 8 por 125 es 1000 que es justo
lo que quería, entonces si yo cancelo, todos
estos se van y me queda solamente 0 y después
bajo el siguiente 0 y 0 cabe 0 veces en 125
y entonces puros 0 por aquí
y ya tengo la respuesta, ¡80! 80 era mi cantidad inicial que yo tenía en mi cartera
y si mi cartera crece en un 25% en una cierta cantidad de tiempo, entonces
después de esa cierta cantidad de tiempo
voy a tener 100 pesos.
80 pesos es mi cantidad inicial, justo lo
que yo estaba buscando.
Fíjate bien, si a 80 pesos tú le aumentas
1/4 de 80 pesos, 1/4 de 80 pesos pues es,
80 entre 4 es 20, es decir le aumentas 20
pesos, pues va a llegar a 100 pesos, que es
justo lo que nosotros queríamos, 1.25 por
80 nos va a dar 100 pesos.
Y bueno, espero que no te confundan estos
problemas, sin embargo,
estaba pensando en hacer próximamente un video que tenga que ver también con este tipo de problemas.
Así que sería bastante bueno que revisaras
otra vez este video
y no te pierdas nuestro siguiente video.